Hola Muy Bienvenidos a la entrevista de
Franz 24 en español el movimiento de
protestas que comenzó en septiembre tras
la muerte de la joven kurdo iraní maxa a
mini mientras estaba bajo custodia
policial en Irán por supuestamente
llevar mal colocado su velo se convirtió
en toda una Revolución sin precedentes
que traspasó la fronteras de Irán y esto
en medio de una cruda represión que deja
según la organización de Derechos
Humanos
cerca de 500 personas muertas y al menos
16 condenados a muerte sin embargo las
iraníes siguen manteniéndose contra el
régimen que las oprime nos acompaña Maya
ostobares ya es activista iraní por los
derechos de las mujeres abandonó Irán
hace 10 años y se ha transformado en una
potente voz en la lucha por la igualdad
de las mujeres y sus derechos sobre sus
cuerpos
Muchas gracias por estar en Fran
4 gracias por la invitación
Maya empecemos por el uso de hillary
las mujeres tienen que usarlo
obligatoriamente en Irán no tienen la
posibilidad de elegir para usted Qué
representa el
experience
tengo una experiencia de haber vivido en
Irán durante 25 años y bajo la sharía
bajo la República islámica así que ya
para mí y para muchas otras iraníes para
muchas mujeres que han vivido bajo la
ideología islámica es el símbolo más
visible de opresión hacia las mujeres
significa por ejemplo que en la
República islámica de Irán cuando uno
entra al país
lo primero que ve y que lo hace entender
que entró a la República islámica de
Irán es ver que todas las mujeres sin
importar Quiénes sean si creen en el
islam o no Si tienen otra religión de
que etnia son ni siquiera importa si son
iraníes o no tienen que ponerse unjilla
entonces a partir de ese uso obligatorio
del uno entiende que está en la
República islámica
desde el principio cuando este régimen
tomó el poder una de las primeras cosas
que querían hacer era controlar a las
mujeres y los cuerpos de Las mujeres
[Música]
así que empezaron con el uso obligatorio
se lo impusieron a las mujeres y
pusieron diferentes herramientas para
controlarlo Porque no ven a las mujeres
como ciudadanas con los mismos derechos
que los hombres
mujeres son básicamente ciudadanas de
segunda clase y esta es la forma de
oprimir y controlar a las mujeres
Maya cree que esta obligación de usar el
más una decisión política que religiosa
es ambas cosas porque la República
islámica es una teocracia es una
dictadura pero está basada en ideologías
islámicas por eso una de las primeras
cosas que el pueblo Irán y quiere ahora
mismo con su revolución con sus
protestas es el laicismo para el futuro
de Irán
Porque así es como se ve una dictadura
cuando una religión está en el poder
cuando una ideología así está en el
poder por lo que no se puede decir que
no sea una decisión religiosa
es exactamente lo que se ve también en
Afganistán cuando la ideología islámica
cuando el islamismo está en el poder Así
es como tratan a las mujeres o como
quieren controlar los cuerpos de las
mujeres
Yo diría que es tanto una decisión
religiosa como política es la
combinación de política y religión lo
que que esto suceda
para tener un futuro mejor para que todo
el mundo pueda vivir una vida y elegir
el estilo de vida que quiere para que
las mujeres sean libres y puedan elegir
lo que quieren ponerse Cómo quieren
vivir y tener control sobre su cuerpo
sobre su vida necesitamos el laicismo
necesitamos que la religión sea cual sea
ya sea el islam u otra religión esté
separada de la política y eso es lo que
no tenemos en países como Irán ahora
mismo o Afganistán bajo el régimen
talibán
hablemos de este movimiento masivo en
todo Irán Qué diferencia estas
manifestaciones tras la muerte de las
protestas anteriores la muerte de maxa
fue un punto de inflexión
exactamente ciertamente creo que fue un
punto de inflexión y creo que muchos
iraníes estarían de acuerdo conmigo
porque como saben Esta no es la primera
vez que los iraníes salen a las calles
durante estos 40 años hemos visto
protestas muchas veces pero una de las
cosas en las que la mayoría de los
iraníes estarían de acuerdo ahora mismo
es que esta vez es diferente esta vez se
siente diferente para todos en primer
lugar porque las exigencias son muy
radicales están dirigidas a todo el
régimen lo que quieren es una Revolución
ya no quieren la República islámica y la
gente es muy valiente
sabe que pueden ser asesinados en la
calle han visto que mucha gente jóvenes
adolescentes han sido asesinados en las
calles o han sido arrestados y
ejecutados pero no le tienen miedo a eso
creen que ya es hora y no quieren más
este gobierno
la otra cosa que ha cambiado diría yo es
que ahora la revolución Se ha producido
en las Mentes y en los corazones de la
gente por lo que ahora pueden imaginarse
un futuro sin la República islámica de
Irán
esto no era algo fácil de imaginar hace
4 meses no pensábamos cuando podremos
librarnos de la República islámica
pero una de las cosas que la gente como
yo o estoy segura de que muchos iraníes
puede imaginarse ahora mismo es un país
sin este régimen
Así que yo diría que la revolución es un
proceso cambiar este régimen es un
proceso muy difícil porque tienen mucho
poder tienen la parte militar que los
respalda pero estamos seguros de que va
a suceder y este es un punto de
inflexión
hablemos de cierto relativismo cultural
que durante mucho tiempo ha marcado este
tema hasta el día de hoy
liberal voices y bien from the ciertas
voces liberales incluso sectores de
izquierda y algunas feministas de
occidente habían dicho muchas veces
cosas como lo que está pasando en Irán
es una cuestión cultural no podemos
hablar del Hi Java aquí en esta parte
del mundo o no podemos hablar de lo que
supuestamente eligieron las mujeres en
contextos islámicos
cree que este tipo de pensamientos
tienen el efecto negativo de silenciar
los problemas de los derechos de las
mujeres iraníes
claro para mí ha sido muy difícil
irrumpir
es muy triste porque las voces los
grupos de los que esperábamos ver apoyo
por ejemplo feministas progresistas
grupos de izquierda hasta ahora hasta
antes de esta Revolución guardaron mucho
silencio sobre lo que ocurría en la
República islámica de Irán con las
mujeres
como usted lo dijo debido a este
relativismo cultural porque creen que
valores como la libertad la igualdad
entre hombres y mujeres no son algo
universal y que si eso no existe en
países como Irán es porque así es su
cultura
y lo que estamos viendo en Irán es que
eso no es lo que cree el pueblo iraní y
lo que quiere son exactamente esos
valores universales
están luchando por la libertad están
luchando por la igualdad entre hombres y
mujeres tienen la Consigna progresista
más radical mujer vida libertad que es
muy universal creen en eso y están
luchando con sus vidas para lograrlo
esto muestra lo errónea que era esta
visión del relativismo cultural y lo
perjudicial que fue porque
desgraciadamente
no fue la primera mujer que fue tratada
así por la policía de la moralidad O la
policía del jiyab en Irán esa es la vida
cotidiana de las mujeres iraníes esta
violencia ha sido la vida cotidiana de
las mujeres iraníes durante más de 40
años
pero algunos occidentales les tomó mucho
tiempo estuvo más de 40 años y fue
necesaria una vida preciosa como la de
maxa Mimí para comprender la opresión de
las mujeres dentro de Irán y apoyar
finalmente a las mujeres iraníes
Y eso es muy difícil porque podría haber
ocurrido mucho antes es decir en
términos de opresión y violencia nada ha
cambiado siempre ha sido así durante
estos 40 años y las mujeres llevan más
de 40 años luchando contra esto pero no
las habían apoyado hasta ahora
Esta es una de las primeras veces que
las iraníes se sienten apoyadas que
sienten que los occidentales por ejemplo
las feministas occidentales y los medios
de comunicación occidentales las ven y
las escuchan y eso está muy bien Me
alegro mucho de que por fin haya
ocurrido pero lo que quiero decir es que
podría haber ocurrido mucho antes
vaya qué posibles escenarios prevé para
las próximas semanas o meses
honestamente no es fácil de predecir
como dije antes las revoluciones toman
tiempo por supuesto
es un punto de inflexión no vamos a
volver a donde estábamos hace 4 meses y
eso se puede ver porque ahora mismo
muchas mujeres en la calle en público ya
no llevan
al que sigue siendo obligatorio serían a
ponérselo como símbolo de protesta
las cosas que están haciendo los actos
de protesta que vemos por ejemplo quemar
cosas quemar el velo esas son imágenes
esos son actos muy muy radicales Y si
algo así está ocurriendo significa que
la gente está harta de la república
islámica
que está harta por ejemplo de que la
obliguen a ponerse el hillary o de hacer
lo que les impone la ideología islámica
es un punto de inflexión pero llevará
tiempo
necesitamos por supuesto más apoyo de
los gobiernos occidentales necesitamos
que realicen acciones reales más serias
que apoyen a la gente en lugar de la
República islámica y esperamos Ver que
esto suceda
Maya ostobar Muchas gracias por estar en
la entrevista de France 24 gracias
muchas gracias muchas gracias y a
nuestra audiencia le invitamos a que
sigan informándose en el resto de
nuestra programación y también por
supuesto en 24.com sigan junto a
nosotros
[Música]